hey Brad Pitt Brad I love you sorry
about this um I think they got my
I think they got my name wrong
yeah it's Mrs Pitt
Brad Pitt wins most popular at the 2023
Golden Globe awards well you're you're
in the know the actor didn't take home
any awards Tuesday night but as he sat
front row he received lots of love from
his friends and famous admirers
including Golden Globe winner Austin
Butler is Once Upon a Time in Hollywood
co-star gave Brad a short but sweet
shout out during his acceptance speech I
just am so grateful right now I'm in
this room full of my heroes Brad I love
you you
get up on stage for one thing just
seeing all those people that are my
absolute Heroes but then you look at the
clock and it says 30 seconds
your time is up
move it along and you just start trying
to I'm still getting used to these types
of things so Abbott Elementary star
Quinta Bronson also took home a trophy
Brad's not affiliated with her hit ABC
sitcom but he was still top of her mind
comedy comedy is so important to me
comedy brings people together comedy
gives us all the same laugh
hey Brad Pitt
um
and get this Quinta's co-star Janelle
James also had Brad on the brain after
the show's Big Win were you headed next
where am I to the after party today
after to rub shoulders with Brad Pitt
and stuff the likes of him was it crazy
him sitting right down there in the
front yeah I I totally someone I I know
I heard that he was here but to see him
in person as well some people you
shouldn't see outside of the screen I'm
like what are you doing outside Brad
Pitt what are you doing outside you
should be in a famous man uh location
then there's Regina Hall who teased host
Gerard Carmichael for announcing her
name wrong yeah it's Mrs Pitt
foreign
is right here so I'm so sorry honey
now really that was really disrespectful
so how did Brad feel about basically
being the knights prom King well an
eyewitness inside the show tells E.T he
looked relaxed and was smiling he even
raised a glass of water with his Babylon
co-star Margot Robbie whom he sat with
quote he also seemed to be cracking
jokes to make her laugh throughout the
evening that's it man we're just gonna
die so let's like let's have some fun
before we go out we're also told Brad
hung out with his other Babylon co-star
Gene smart as well as Ozark star Julia
Garner who looked Starstruck after
meeting the Oscar winner Brad also
rubbed shoulders with Colin Farrell
Brandon Gleason Donald Glover and
director Quentin Tarantino and Brad
showed there were no hard feelings as he
posed with actor kihi Kwan who beat him
in the best supporting actor category I
kid you now when they read my name in
fact I I everything was blurry uh uh uh
I I you know I uh I didn't know what I
was feeling like I said earlier it's
been 38 years this stream has been in 38
years making yeah so maybe no trophy but
we think Brad won the night
foreign